and that is praising outside the window
yeah yeah my wife happy
all my parties who yes gran my lifetime
[Music]
look at it yeah
none of our doing I think suffering
although this feels cook it up I hit
that with no water in it on Tina quickly
[Laughter]
which he used to kick it out of me that
I knew something's working right look
gentlemen it's back there you go
constructed that type of Wednesday wait
to you see we got to you today
look at this [__] creature look at
his hand of debt look at this little bit
you guys tell me you get this down the
block and Milwaukee's Lotus it looks
like a [__] hook it looks like a
camel toe look at it this way through
this [__] we're going to sing
beautiful that's the type of stuff we
have to easily take on the Churchill
what happens now construction
I love I love it this light and so I
touched up and get ready to die today
and it's biggie smalls day ready to
[__] die yes
- water in the afternoon you've got a
reasonable deserve than half yet it
might but I don't have that another top
that we love that once the light comes
with all his not been so [__] on you
God do these days we [__] night we
have indictment so does it even the
stuff gets too hot like to confuse with
that [__] won't take welcome to up the
Carpinteria by Sambora and it's like I
checked the weather my under six degrees
and at 76 for canary missing that drive
is dropped 30 degrees
listen it will be F was nightly here
slightly 60 L can change your mindset
and you leave the valley its nightly
give yo eif LAX it's gently same day
what the people landed they think it's
beautiful here where we go and called
hell bat okay
consider the other car Calabasas oxen Oh
realize I'm up there in Hidden Hills
right bike helmet and it's funny
greetings from the Lord humungus we're
here [__] the 550th anniversary
of the church what's happened now
because the you savages I love you
[__] we had a great guest view
today we got a great co-host for you
today and that's all you need to know
it's going to be a cool seat come Sade
maybe a couple stars nothing too heavy
just we gotta take this party to the ice
house tonight so let's start till 8:30
but guess what
it's sold out you [__] up that's what
happens when you [__] [__] around but
as usual we're just going to get the
party started Maui because tonight is
the second half this is a two [__]
chapter EP oK we've got the four o'clock
session and then we will [__]
periscope you again at about 10 o'clock
to show you the condition of what we're
looking like look at these [__] tent
looks pleasing just like that no drama
no rehab no hugs I don't mean nothing
I don't need nothing for money is like
that like that all right that if you're
not even edibles like that you're
wasting your [__] time go hang out at
Starbucks a little goofy white friends
talk about whatever the [__] you talk
about but it's over that's it we're
going deep tonight and I got an 8:30
spot you understand me who do you see
doing this at 4 o'clock for an 8:30 spot
all right you might not like me but you
gotta [__] respect that's all I'm
sayin you may not like me but you gotta
respect me cuz I don't [__] around
alright I'm not one of these ho ho
[__] with a medical marijuana
license and [__] talking nonsense here
but I bond it together and get this
party started I just want to check in
with you and tell you from the bottom of
my nan these hearts that we love you to
death Thank You 500 episode you know
what what tip top Magoo Mondays and
Wednesdays we don't give a [__] of this
earthquake
we'll do a podcast from under a bridge
and we don't give a [__]
well here for you [__] but you
here for us so thank you very much we
love you with all our [__] heart
look like who wants to do a fungus if
you're Nadine hang up right now
[__] I don't want your mom calling
me tonight telling me you sniff the
[__] bras huh
I used to sniff frogs when I was a kid
not my mom my aunt I was [__] crazy
in Miami I would slip a little bras and
she had the remember of it and when we
were kids they had that every mother had
the [__] hot water bottle watch their
[__] kids wear a long tube I used to
slip that tube in the shower given sniff
the tube in the shower tremendous it
smells like vinegar and [__]
something else but who knew when you're
a kid you don't know nothing so [__] it
some of these salads in the shower hit
him saying we got to fill this up that
was a dud it was like a [__] fire
cracker from Ming melting it was it done
but when we thrown at you today what's
wrong this is what Pablo Escobar smoked
the season 2 on next week and this is
[__] blue cookies look at that that
when I [__] around for that I told
you people you don't know what you're
missing if you want to get to the Voodoo
Lounge hitchhike
we're right here we'll be here too but I
don't know I don't [__] them we might
not even make it to the ice house we
might do the show via periscope from
right here in [__] @h you rectly
you're ready for Barney the one-on-one
how many stars you know you you put them
in your pocket you save them for later
you're gonna send musa eyetality which
was the following to get periscope
oh my goodness look at that that [__]
beautiful that's the way it should be
you ready for a bunion we cleaned out
the pipe today everything is ready to go
we're not [__] around it's not like
what's that place of the pipes are
leaking the hot air the Griffin Trench
whatever yeah you know that the [__]
pollution is bad there's a gas thing
that's leaking then the judge ruled in
kind of tracking right the lab where
they drilling for like the in the sample
order I don't know some [__] thinking
well they shot [__] a lone ranger I
don't know what they should oh um legs
that's um trivia for you of your whole
team when they shoot the long way -
what's up here they shot the long rage
and mash and all that [__] up there
caramel branches or something rash
there's a gas leak order an order ranch
yes miss Miller [__] ass killing
[__]
but there's so much Dida that the judge
rules against the people like joking in
court and I was a pop yeah yeah yeah
yeah where's welcome what's an idea by
the 118 by the 118 right there
where's Robert with Julia Roberts when
you need it jumping over [__] fence
that she was on that movie she look good
with the two kids you had the dirty
boyfriend but it's time for Julia
Roberts and the other one to show that
pussy's cool not Julia Roberts as much
as the other one
what's the other one man Sandra Bullock
needs to show a [__] she died the last
three movies it's over sender they got
to show that monkey from the side some
even the chick from friends shoulder
don't feel bad you got it and she got a
million episode again I'm saying let's
go you want to a bunker before we get
this party
she got a million episode that she had
to show a little titties with [__]
what's-his-name and the movie about to
Chicago whatever this is bond it's
raining 101 with doing super sets look
at this leaf on this flat look at you
look at you what is real there you go
[Music]
that we was so [__] good hey ten
minutes youtube.com - splash ceaseless
Joey did Fitz on the episode five
minutes youtube.com classy flash Joey
Diaz
we love you [__] thank you
without you we got thick
[Music]